I know what my father was what he did I
know the Mad King earned his name
every Targaryen I get my hands on
as an enemy
so is it bring these hey what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season eight and
game theory video today I want to talk
about the White Walkers and the
mysterious symbols they leave behind we
have seen these patterns multiple times
throughout the series but the question
still remains the same why do they do
this and what does it mean in the
opening scene of the very first episode
of Game of Thrones season 1 we see three
Rangers from the Nights Watch go beyond
the wall on a mission to track wildlings
during their mission one of them comes
across body parts that are arranged in a
horrific way what do you expect the
savages one not steals a goat from
another lot before you know they're
ripping each other to pieces I never
seen wildlings do a thing like this I
never seen a thing like it's not ever in
my life these symbols are presented to
us in the opening scene of the show
which always led me to believe they were
very important but what do they mean the
second time was in season 31 Mance
Rayder Jon Snow and the other wildlings
went to the fist of the first men to
confirm the Nights Watch men were killed
but instead they saw dead horse heads
and body parts placed in a large spiral
[Music]
always the artists
[Music]
[Music]
after seeing this man says always the
artists which sounds like this is not
the first time he is seeing these
symbols left by the White Walkers he
might have seen these several times
before this could be the first clue that
the White Walkers have some form of
intelligence
unlike the White's who act almost like
zombies the interesting thing is the
White Walkers aren't the only ones who
use these symbols we have also seen this
what the children of the forest the
spiral pattern was also present at the
time of the night Kings creation and the
pattern still remains there till this
day although it is now frozen over in it
the spiral can be seen in a stonework
pattern with the weirwood tree at its
heart considering the connection between
the children and the White Walkers one
would assume that would be the end of
the mystery clearly the knight King is
mimicking or mocking the children but
then it showed up again in the season 7
promo trailer so now I wonder if there
is greater significance could it be in
relation to magic or some form of a
ritual as we know by now symbolism plays
a big role in the game of Thrones the
swirl that we see in the trailer is
similar to the one that surrounded the
tree when the children of the forest
made the first white Walker since they
stem from the children of the forest
they must have picked up on a few
symbols and adapted them these symbols
could also be seen as a warning to the
men letting them know that they won't be
facing a bunch of ice zombies but
instead they will be facing creatures
that can think and process information
and have a final goal we have very
little information about the aim of the
White Walkers so it would be tough to
interpret the signs but they must have
some meaning to them what's interesting
about the White Walkers corpse patterns
is that these symbols aren't seen in the
books when the Nights Watch Ranger well
describes the dead wailings he found he
says nothing about them being in any
sort of pattern
I don't recall the others making a
spiral that john sees with man's either
I suppose it is possible that they
wanted to make the others even more
mysterious in the show these symbols
could also be connected to the phrase
the North remembers the children of the
forest created the night king
to fight the first man but the night
king didn't turn out to work the way
that it was intended to so the wall was
built to imprison the night king and the
other white walkers in the north I would
say that the night king is probably
pissed off and tired of living beyond
the wall for thousands of years when the
children made the night King the
ceremony included those same seven lines
of stones in a spiral pattern with the
person dead senator since they are
reproducing that symbol it might be his
way to tell people that he remembers and
it's a reminder to those who also use
these symbols after all he made us be
arraigned a man that got kidnapped and
transformed into a white Walker
everything was taken away from him by
the children so in his mind he's the
good guy who once revenge they could be
leaving these as a message to the
children of the forest this would let
the children know that he's back and
he's coming for them but that's just a
guess these symbols aren't the only
thing the White Walkers have adapted
they have also used another pattern that
we see in the very first episode of the
series as well when Ned Stark beheads
the man from the Nights Watch there is a
circular pattern of stones around the
stump where the man is placed in the
center this symbol is also seen when the
knight King turns the baby into a white
Walker there are large pieces of ice in
a circular pattern with a block in the
senator since the knight King is also
using these symbols this could be
another hint at the knight Kings
northern routes the knight king
ceremonial grounds remind me of the
Starks ned uses his location to end life
while the knight King uses his to
possibly give eternal life it's very
interesting
there is also that scene in the cave on
Dragonstone in the scene john leads Dany
into the caves to check out these cave
paintings created by none other than the
children of the forest
they were here together the children in
the first man doing what fighting each
other
[Music]
in the paintings we see what's assumed
to be the war for the dawn a
generational long battle where the first
men and the children teamed up against a
White Walkers during the scene John says
they fought together against their
common enemy despite their differences
despite their suspicions we need to do
the same if we're going to survive
because the enemy is real it's always
been real but did you notice many of the
cave paintings also had symbols we've
seen in the past perhaps these symbols
appeared the last time the White Walkers
were around just before the fighting
truly begun but why would they go out of
their way to create these symbols in the
first place I don't know if any of you
watch the post-show after this episode
but you might have heard David Benioff
explained that the White Walkers aren't
even the ones who came up with these
symbols it was actually the children of
the forest which we did find out in
season six
but Benioff goes on to say one of the
things we learned from these cave
paintings is that the White Walkers did
not come up with those images they
derived from their creators the children
of the forest these patterns have
mystical significance for the children
of the forest and we're not exactly sure
what they signify but spiral patterns
are important in a lot of different
cultures in our world and it makes sense
that they would be in this world as well
so what exactly do the symbols mean or
the children of the forest trying to
tell us something
or the White Walkers trying to
communicate something do they still
recall being made by the children of the
forest according to the television show
the children of the forest created the
White Walkers by inserting dragonglass
into the heart of a captured first man
it was an act of desperation meant to
protect them from the men who threatened
their lives and land we don't know
exactly what went wrong or how the
children lost control of the White
Walkers but they eventually and
ironically became an even greater threat
than the first men the children and the
men created a pact that divided their
land and promised a peaceful coexistence
but eventually the White Walkers
descended from wherever they were being
kept to wage a war against their
creators since the White Walkers also
leave these symbols I assume it's tied
into their connection with the children
of the forest but I think it is more
than just foreshadowing their creation
because they continue to show these
patterns well after we learned how the
night king was created it's hard to say
if the spirals will ever mean anything
specific or significant and what's left
of Game of Thrones or if they're only
meant to draw a connection between the
children and the White Walkers
but since David Benioff chose to
emphasize their significance that
probably means at the very least we will
get some kind of an answer in the end
what do all of you think about these
mysterious patterns or symbols are they
important or did the producers just want
to add another cool visual with the
White Walkers let me know what you think
about them put your thoughts down below
anyways I want to thank you all for
watching the video and I want to give a
big shout out to everyone that supports
the channel on patreon thank you all so
much I hope you have a great day I will
see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]